>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Maureen Corrigan: I just told
Hannah Pittard and Elizabeth Hand
that I was a little afraid of them.
And if you are readers
of their wonderful
and slightly disturbing
fiction, more than slightly,
you know what I'm talking about.
They're both such inventive writers
who really take readers like us
into places that we
couldn't even imagine.
And what I find after
reading both of,
especially their most recent novels,
is that I can't get
images out of my head.
And I can't forgive
them for some images.
This is for you.
So some of them know
what I'm talking about.
Hannah Pittard is the author
of three novels, Reunion,
The Fates Will Find Their Way, and
her most recent novel, Listen to Me.
She's published short stories in
American Scholar and McSweeney's
and teaches fiction at the
University of Kentucky.
Listen to Me, in particular,
has garnered the kind of praise
that just gladdens
an author's heart.
It is an editor's choice of
the New York Times Book Review.
It was also selected by
the Washington Post as one
of the top suspense novels
to read this past summer.
Elizabeth Hand is the
bestselling author of 13 novels
and four collections
of short fiction.
And she spans almost
every type of genre
that you could possible think
of, speculative fiction,
fantasy fiction, horror fiction,
crime novels, noir,
she's done it all.
She has won among other awards the
World Fantasy Award four times,
the Nebula Award twice, the
Shirley Jackson Award twice,
and the International Horror
Guild Award three times.
I had the pleasure of reviewing
Elizabeth's latest Cass Neary novel,
Hard Light, for the
Post a few months ago.
It's her third in her series
featuring Cass Neary who's a
hard-living photographer and
also described as a woman
of a certain age with
substance abuse issues.
Like her novel Walking the Moon,
which I read some 20 years ago,
it is something that I now
can't get out of my brain.
So I want you to please welcome me
in thanking Hannah
Pittard and Elizabeth Hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Hannah Pittard: Thank you.
That was well put.
>> Maureen Corrigan:
Where do we start?
I want to start with your
killer first sentences.
Each of you have written first
sentences that, you know,
when I open up a book and I think
okay, especially if it's a choice.
Do I go further with
this novel or not?
It's not just the ingenuity
of your first sentences,
it's the authority of the voices.
It's the sly wit.
So Elizabeth, your latest
Cass Neary novel, Hard Light,
begins a stolen passport
will only get you so far.
And Hannah, your first sentence
is, they were on the road later
than they intended, sorry.
They were on the road
later than they intended.
I'm yours for the rest of the novel.
I wanted to know, first of all,
I think it would be helpful.
Not everyone has read your latest
work, if you could give us a sense
of what follows from those openings.
And also, maybe talk about how
important the first sentence,
the first paragraph is,
particularly to a suspense novel.
To a crime novel.
Are the stakes higher
with that kind of novel
than with straight literary fiction?
>> Hannah Pittard: I
think that they can be.
Absolutely.
For me, you have to set up a
lot in that opening sentence,
in the opening chapter, in the
opening paragraph, that by the end
of the book, everything comes back
into light in a different way.
That things viewed initially
change and morph by the end.
But that the clues and the germ is
there, are there, at the beginning.
And it's essential
that Mark and Maggie
who are taking this road trip
together, it's absolutely essential
that how they begin
that road trip is other
than how they expected to begin.
Because everything that
happens afterwards,
and causality is a huge part of
this novel, and it's something
that I'm very interested
in as a writer.
But the fact that the
road trip begins other
than it should is responsible for
the events that unfold at the end.
And the tragedy that occurs at the
novel's end would not have happened
if they had, arguably,
if they had gotten off
at the right time or earlier.
If they'd missed the traffic
jam, if they'd been able
to drive all the way through instead
of having to stop at a hotel.
>> Elizabeth Hand: Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's,
I agree with Hannah.
I think it's sort of a matter
of you never get a second chance
to make a first impression.
And I think with suspense
novels or with noir,
even more than with other kinds of
fiction where, you know, as a reader
and a reviewer, I always
read the beginning
and the end of a book first.
I always pick it up.
I read the first sentence,
I read the ending.
And I've done that my whole life.
And I think I've had to
learn over the years how
to write a first sentence.
And I think in particular with
writing, you know, noir novels,
suspense novels, there's more of a
weight on it because readers come
to those kind of stories with
different kinds of expectations
than you bring to another
kind of a book.
So I think that other kinds
of fiction you obviously want
to have a hook from
the very beginning.
You do want to have a
strong opening sentence.
But I think that with more
quote/unquote, literary fiction,
people can ease into the story more.
Whereas, with a suspense novel or
a crime novel, the expectations
of a reader that you bring into it,
you want to immediately
be there in media rest.
You want to be there as it starts.
You want to be there in the, you
know, stuck in traffic trying to,
you know, get to where you're going.
>> Hannah Pittard: Or
with a passport that's.
>> Elizabeth Hand:
Yeah, leave the storm.
>> Hannah Pittard:
The stolen passport.
>> Elizabeth Hand: Yeah
or the stolen passport.
So I think there's that sense
of immediacy that your book has.
And though I have tried
to get in particular
with the Cass Neary novels.
>> Maureen Corrigan: But,
you've already touched on it,
but you both resurrected the
journeyism [phonetic] motif.
Cass goes on a journey
in Hard Light.
You've got Maggie and Mark
in this car with their dog.
I mean it's as old as the Odyssey.
You mention the Iliad.
You start off with that
epigraph from the Iliad.
How do you rejuvenate the
journey as a motif for a story?
>> I think it's, I can't
remember who was the first person
to teach me this because I've heard
it so many times and I teach it
so often now, but if you make
your characters want something,
that makes them relatable.
It makes them interesting.
And for me, with Listen to
Me, there is this very easy,
natural thing that they both want.
That is the concrete visceral thing.
They want to get to
Charlottesville, Virginia.
It's very easy.
Existentially, they
want other things.
You know, Mark wants
his normal wife back.
Maggie wants to lose the
feelings of paranoia.
She wants to be normal again too.
But I love the road trip.
I think, I think it's a
very American type story.
I think Lolita is a road trip
novel and a great one at that.
And also a thriller and a mystery.
And you know, I begin my novel with
that nod to the Iliad which is this,
on the one hand it's the
story of a ten-year war.
But it's, you know, Homer
does this great trick.
He tells us only about the
last three weeks of the war.
But in telling us about those
last three weeks of the war,
he fills in the ten years.
And Listen to Me does something
sort of similar in many ways.
We're only with Mark and Maggie for
24 hours, but the trick of the book,
if it's successful,
is to sort of fill
in a ten-year marriage
in just those 24 hours.
You're going to ask
questions and I'm going
to constantly not answer them.
Or switch [inaudible].
>> Elizabeth Hand: And I
think too the other thing
with your novel is it's a road trip,
which is this very
American trope in fiction.
But it's also something just
about all of us have done
at some point in our life.
And many of us have had this
awful claustrophobic, you know,
sense of being trapped in a car with
someone, whether you're, you know,
trying to get home from college
or Thanksgiving weekend or you're
with your spouse on vacation
and you've left too
late to get somewhere.
Or you're a kid trapped in
the car with your parent.
Or you're a teenager
trapped with your parent,
which is like the worst
thing in the world.
And so I think you evoke
this kind of, you know,
very iconic American
Experience with that.
With the cast novels in particular,
which Hard Light is the third one,
she's a character who is, you know,
old fashioned pinball machines
where the ball would be in play
and it's just bouncing around.
You're trying to keep it moving
without going down the chute.
She's kind of like a ball in play.
Her life has been in stasis
for many decades living
on the lower east side of Manhattan.
And in the first novel she is kind
of tempted out of her lair and goes
up to, you know, an island off the
coast of Maine and hijinks ensue.
And then in the second
book she goes to Reykjavik.
And in the third one
she's in London.
And she's basically on the lam.
She's kind of on the run.
So she's now in a place
on a stolen passport,
but she's always pretty
much an outsider.
So she's not, and I think
that's an experience
that Americans can have
a lot in this country.
You know, because we're defined.
If we're not defined by, we live in
different regions that, you know,
living in downtown Manhattan
it's very different from living
in rural Maine or from
living in, you know,
the panhandle of Texas
or something like that.
So and then if you go abroad,
your sense of being an outsider
can be really magnified.
So in that sense, it's kind
of a journey of what it's
like to be the ugly American in your
own country and then somewhere else.
>> Maureen Corrigan: Yeah.
I want to talk about weather,
because both of your novels,
you know, are just in a
sense extreme adventure tales
about weather as well.
You've got a tornado going
on in Look at Me, impending,
which is also a great
device to knock out the GPS
and everything else that we rely on.
>> Hannah Pittard: I'd do
anything to get rid of technology.
I'll set it in 1980.
>> Maureen Corrigan: Yeah.
>> Hannah Pittard: I'll do anything.
>> Maureen Corrigan: Yeah, yeah.
And when Cass arrives in
London there's a monstrous hail
and rainstorm going on that the
likes of which hasn't been seen
in what, 300 years or something?
I mean it's fun weather as
almost another character.
But I did feel in both your novels
that the weather was also this way
to sort of peel off that
skin of normalcy and say,
things can get really weird
in ordinary life really fast.
And if you'd like to talk about
weather and how you came up with
that device, I'd love
to know about it.
>> Elizabeth Hand: Yeah,
that's interesting.
Because I hadn't thought about it.
I think that's one reason why
I loved your book so much.
I love reading about bad weather.
>> Hannah Pittard: We
both like bad weather.
>> Elizabeth Hand: Yeah it's funny.
Throughout my career,
many of my books and a lot
of my short fiction has had kind of
apocalyptically bad weather in it.
And I think, actually for me I think
it actually goes back to, you know,
my childhood being raised
Catholic and from a very,
very young age this notion
of the end of the world.
Which I could only imagine
was like an earthquake.
Which, you know, I
grew up in Yonkers
where there's not a
lot of earthquakes.
And but I think from watching,
you know, movies or things,
I was really impressed and
frightened by apocalyptic weather.
And then moving to Maine where
basically all people ever talk
about is the weather for
six months of the year.
It's like no one in
Maine has never seen snow
because the way they
talk about the weather.
It's just, you know, of course now
with smartphone technology and,
you know, the disaster Weather
Channel and everything else
and with climate change
that gets intensified.
But yeah, but I'm really,
I'm fascinated by it.
And I've been writing about, and
thinking about climate change for,
you know, almost 20 years.
And seeing a lot of
the things that I wrote
about in earlier speculative fiction
books, sort of near future books,
in which all of these terrible
weather events would happen.
I would never in a
million years have imagined
that actually we're living that now.
You know, when I wrote those books
or stories, it was science fiction.
And now it's like our everyday life.
So, you know, I can't
keep up with it.
So it was very easy
for me to transpose
that say to London or Cornwall.
And these are very fragile
places that we found, you know,
found out here and in
New York after Sandy
and New Orleans and
Vermont after Irene.
Which is not a city, but, you know,
the weather is something
we cannot control.
And where like in your book
on the small scale, you know,
if you're in this little
bubble of a car.
Tornado, that's like
my worst nightmare.
>> Hannah Pittard: Yeah,
I think there's something
about weather that, at least for
me, I am terrified of being out in,
you know, terrific rainstorms.
I don't like driving, I'm
like my grandmother, you know,
I don't like driving
in the rain at all.
But there is, at the
same time, there's this,
it seems like there's
nothing like weather
or the promise of bad weather.
Not when it's actively happening
but just when they're telling you
that it's going to happen to elicit
in me a terrific amount of hubris.
I can see that it's going to 65%
chance that it's going to rain.
I will look my umbrella in the
face as I am leaving and I'll say,
you know, I'm not going
to take the umbrella
because I'm pretty sure
I'm going to time it.
And then I'll stand, I'll stand in
my office and just watch the water
and think, there was the umbrella.
I had space in my bag.
What was I doing?
And so that's a really
small scale version
of what Mark and Maggie
end up doing.
You know, there is a four
state storm that has been going
on for four or five days, because
when they finally get to the hotel
where they're going to stay for the
night, they find out that the people
at the hotel haven't had
potable water for a week.
And yet here is this, you
know, this city folk couple
who presumably has the
television on all the time,
the Weather Channel on all the time.
But they've decided because
they're in Chicago, it's 90 degrees
when they hit the road, how's it
going to happen to them, right?
Why would they run into the storm?
And I just, I love the idea
of something like weather
that is so beyond our control.
And of course, in my book the
weather's just the weather,
but it is also, it's the marriage.
And you can love somebody
as much as you want,
but you cannot control what that
other person's heart is capable of
or what it's going to do.
We just, we only have ourselves
that we are in control of.
And that's if we're lucky.
>> Maureen Corrigan: Yeah, yeah.
>> Hannah Pittard: Sometimes
characters who aren't even
in control of themselves.
>> Maureen Corrigan: You know with
both of your books, it almost felt
to me like the weather served
like the haunted house does
in those old movies from the 30s,
40s, 50s, where the characters
who say, oh there's no
such thing as ghosts.
You know, there's no such
thing as the supernatural.
And they go into the house,
and they're always the first
ones killed or scared to death.
As the weather intensified
in both of the books,
things got weirder and weirder.
One of the scenes I loved in your
book, Hannah, is fairly early on.
Although the weather is looming.
And Mark and Maggie
stop at a gas station.
And she is treated to
one of those comments
that women sometimes get treated to
where a man walks by in a cowboy hat
and comments on her body.
And then she doesn't
know, he acts innocent.
She doesn't know whether
she heard it or not.
>> Elizabeth Hand: Right.
>> Maureen Corrigan: But
things start to get stranger,
almost like there's a
climatic electricity
in the air that's disturbing
the atmosphere.
>> Hannah Pittard: Things go
downhill from there in a slight way.
And I was, I reread that chapter
not long after writing it.
And I don't think it was until then
and the comment that this man made
and the doubt that Maggie feels.
Did he say it?
Did he not say it?
I don't think it was until I
reread that chapter that I realized
that I was writing a thriller.
Because I was scared by it.
And I was really uncomfortable
with what a gentleman he seemed
to be after, because she
confronts him slightly.
And he denies it, and he's sweet,
and he waves to his
wife in the distance.
And his wife waves back.
And I made myself really
uncomfortable at that moment.
And I thought, I think this
book might be something other
than what I meant it
to be at the beginning.
And I just sort of
followed that trajectory.
And that man, that character
was supposed to disappear
in the next chapter, which
was Mark's point of view.
I realized that he'd come back,
and he's even creepier
there and more aggressive.
>> Maureen Corrigan: Yes.
And then, of course, if
Cass had been subjected
to that comment, she would.
>> Elizabeth Hand: She
would have just kicked him.
>> Maureen Corrigan: She'd would
have kicked him in the right place.
I see, in at least one
interview, Elizabeth,
you talked about your affection
for characters who were sort
of unlikeable or, and I like
Cass, but I'm not sure that she
and I would do so well if we were
seated next to each other on Amtrak.
She's tough.
She's brisk.
She's not particularly nice.
This issue of unlikeable characters,
especially in novels written
by women, seems to keep
coming up all the time.
I guess Clare Messud in The Woman
Next Door, was that the title?
>> Hannah Pittard: Upstairs.
>> Maureen Corrigan:
Upstairs, thank you.
She was treated to a lot of
criticism about this character
who she had created who didn't
seem particularly likeable.
Is there something defiant
about creating a character
like Cass who, she
isn't a nice girl.
She goes, you know, V.I.
Warshawski, Lisbeth Salander.
All of those other not
nice girl characters.
I think ten times better in
terms of being an outlaw almost.
>> Elizabeth Hand: I didn't, I
was thinking of it consciously
when I created her as a character.
I always, I love Lolita.
I loved the fact that here is a
character, a central character,
a narrator who is, you know,
a pedophile, a kidnapper.
He's this horrible
person, sociopath.
And yet we are seduced by his voice
enough that we read the entire book.
And also by Patricia
Highsmith's Ripley novels.
And I, and many of my
works, earlier books
and stories have had
unsympathetic female characters.
Because I've just found
an interesting perspective
to write from.
And technically, it was sort
of a challenge that I set
for myself with the Cass novels.
How far could I go
with this character
and readers still come
along for the ride.
And it was interesting
because with the first novel,
which came out almost ten years
ago, you know, the reviews of it,
this was before the Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo came
out in this country.
So it was, you know, all the
reviews touched on the fact
that here was this very unlikeable
out there, traumatized person.
But what some of the reviews talked
about as being among her many
transgressions, you know,
being bisexual and, you know, and
alcoholic and an addict and this,
that and the other, was
that she was middle aged.
And that was considered to
be a transgressive element.
And one of my editors
actually asked me
with the second novel
would I make her younger.
And I just like, well
how would that even work?
And I said no, I'm
not going to do that.
So, I wanted to kind
of set that bar and see
where I could go with it, you know.
I think she does have
some redeeming qualities.
I think if she was just a totally,
you know, she may be unlikeable,
but she has a certain kind
of dark charisma, I hope.
I mean she certainly
has a lot of fans
that I think make people
want to read about her.
And also I hear from a lot of
women, a lot of young women.
A lot of women, you know,
of a certain age, mind,
who really relate to her.
And some of them say
yeah, that's me.
I've had those experiences.
And some of them are like oh yeah,
I'm so glad I can be, you know,
my age and I can live vicariously
through a character who's a woman
who's, you know, middle age,
who's doing these things,
and she doesn't give a.
>> Maureen Corrigan: Yeah, yeah.
>> Hannah Pittard: I first
encountered this comment
about having characters, and
specifically female characters,
who are unlikeable when I was still
in school for creative writing.
And I remember a young man who I
liked quite a bit as a human being
and a writer, we were workshopping
a story of mine about a family
and very strong women and the sort
of weaker men that surrounded them.
And he stopped mid-workshop, and
he said, you know what it is.
And he had this southern accent.
And he said you know what it is?
He said, I don't like them.
I don't like a single
woman in this story.
And I remember turning bright
red and, you know, looking down.
And of course I looked down
and I was torn between laughing
and crying, because
there are three women,
and they were 100% me,
my sister and my mom.
And I was like.
I was like, well you
like me, don't you?
All I'm doing is admitting what's
going on behind the surface.
The layers and layers of complicated
complex thoughts that I think most
of us, not just women, have.
But you know, the realization
that boy it would be easier
to lie right now, right.
Just that, on a daily basis.
You know, I just don't
want to say something nice.
I don't want to go to this party.
I don't want to be nice and
polite for a half a second.
I'm tired.
I love this idea of the middle age.
Can you make her younger?
That is just, that makes me want
to make every character older.
>> Elizabeth Hand: Well
it'll happen sooner or later.
You don't need to rush.
>> Maureen Corrigan:
I don't know if either
of you read Rebecca
Traister's interview
with Hillary a few months
ago in which she said
that in her downtime she
loves to read Maisie Dobbs,
and she loves to read
Donna Leon's novel.
And I did think after reading
that interview, as great as,
I mean I love both of those
series for different reasons.
But I kind of wanted
her to pick up Cass.
I thought, a woman of a
certain age acting tough.
Maybe she could learn a little from
Cass about, you know, hanging tough.
I don't know.
I wanted to come back
with you, Hannah,
to talking about the domestic novel.
Because I can't figure out why,
but I feel like we're living
in this sort of golden
age of these novels
that are exploring
marriage from both sides.
And, of course, there's Gone Girl.
I'm just, it just flew
out of my head.
There've been a whole slew of.
>> Hannah Pittard: Fates and Furies.
>> Maureen Corrigan: Fates and
Furies, thank you, Lauren Groff.
Where you're getting a picture
of a marriage from both sides.
And I mean I think one of the things
you do so beautifully is you don't,
Mark and Maggie are both, you
know, they're equally as compelling
as voices and points of view.
And, you know, I kind of found
myself sympathizing with both
of them and also then
distrusting both of them.
I mean why did you decided to write
about a marriage at this point?
>> Hannah Pittard: Up until
last month I was married.
And I sometimes wonder if writing
this book I wasn't channeling,
exercising, some of
the difficulties,
intentions that I was aware of
in my own marriage at the time.
But didn't want to talk
about or weren't coming
to the surface in the right way.
You know, I think like a lot of
writers I definitely go to the pen
and go to the paper when I
should probably be using my words
and talking out loud, and you
know, tapping into my emotions.
But I prefer writing books.
No, I wanted to, it's
really important to me
with every character I write, and
specifically with this couple,
to portray them believably,
and I like every character
I've ever written.
And most of the characters that I've
written have at least gotten one
or two reviews that talk
about their un-likeability.
And I think that they are
all me to a certain extent.
And in going back and forth
between Mark and Maggie,
it was very important to me
to try to tell their stories
from their points of view.
And I think if there's a
reason that I'm a good teacher
or a good listener of other people,
or if there's a reason
I'm a good friend,
it's because before
taking anything personally,
I always try to imagine
wait a minute, I know,
I'm going to keep using
my sister as an example
because she's in the audience.
I know that my sister just
said this terrible thing to me.
But before I get mad at
her, why don't I think
about why she might have said it.
And I try to trace
through all of the reasons
that she might have just
said what she said to me.
And I am always able to, rightly
or wrongly, come up with a reason
that is, that makes sense to me.
And makes me forgive her before
I can even be mad at her.
And so when I'm talking about
this husband and this wife,
what I wanted to do was really
try to tap into their points
of view in an honest way.
So Mark is mad at Maggie because
she was mugged nine months ago,
and she's not back
to normal yet, right.
And on the one hand from
Maggie's perspective
and from Maggie's friends
perspective,
and certainly from Cass'
perspective, Mark is an asshole
for not being more patient.
But on the other hand,
from Mark's point of view,
when you're reading his chapters,
it's because he loves her so much.
And he misses what they had.
And it's the impatience is
because he doesn't truly understand
the extent of her suffering.
And part of that fault is
because she's not using her words
in the right way to
the right extent.
So I think anybody who's
married or anybody who's
in a long-term relationship
with a sibling, with a brother,
a sibling is a brother, with
a brother, a parent, a dog,
you understand that
there are ebbs and flows.
And the reason that
they last, if they last,
is because at some point
you start being able to try
to at least put yourself
in their shoes.
And I just, I wanted to take apart
I guess my marriage and take apart.
This is a crazy institution that
many of us voluntarily enter into.
It's insanity.
>> Maureen Corrigan: No,
I love the visual of them
in the car, down the road of life.
That's kind of sometimes
what it feels like.
And, you know, there's no exit.
>> Hannah Pittard: Chris
Tillman told me famously,
and I use this in class
all the time.
If you don't know what to write
about, put two people in a car
who don't like each other
or who are fighting.
Something is going to happen, right.
They think they can stay
quiet for 500 miles.
They can't.
They're going to have
to talk at some point.
>> Maureen Corrigan: You've
got two people in the car,
but you've got three
sentient beings.
Those are now approved,
have been now acknowledged
as sentient beings,
in France at least.
Yes.
>> Hannah Pittard: That is terrific.
>> Maureen Corrigan: Isn't it great?
I know. They're taking care of
their dog, who I love the scenes
where they keep running out
into this rain, urging this dog
to please do his business.
And he's taking his sweet time.
>> Hannah Pittard: Has anyone ever
tried to walk a dog in the rain
to make it use the bathroom?
It's impossible.
>> Maureen Corrigan: And Cass
in a certain way is taking care
of a young girl at
points in Hard Light.
Again, it struck me that
certainly this caretaking business,
being responsible for somebody or a
creature who isn't quite as capable,
it added to the suspense
of both stories.
Were there other reasons why
you threw these dependents
into the story?
>> Elizabeth Hand: Well I
did it because, you know,
I wanted to have a means by
which Cass could demonstrate some
compassion, almost despite herself.
Which she's shown before.
I mean she, you know, in Generation
Lost she helps this, you know,
helps find this, or looks
for this runaway girl.
And nothing really
analogous in the second book.
But in this one I wanted to kind
of return to that because it seemed
to me it would be something that
would come out of her character.
That she is somebody, she
was very damaged herself
when she was a young woman.
And when she sees, you know,
homeless kids on the street,
when she meets the young girl
Sam in West Penwith and Cornwall,
this sort of very androgynous
young person, you know,
she's kind of drawn to them.
And with Sam she kind of
recognizes herself in a way.
And so even though she's not, you
know, Cass, a warm and fuzzy person,
you know, I think even
people who are.
If we're going to be
honest in looking
at depicting unlikeable people,
you know, and this is something
when I'm dealing with my writing
students I tell them, you know,
the villains in a story do not
perceive themselves as villains.
The villains on the real world
stage do not see themselves
as the bad guys or the bad women.
And I think it's important
if you have an antagonist
or if you have a flawed protagonist
to kind of show all of that.
You know, if you have an antagonist,
that person has some
humane traits somewhere
at some point in their life.
Maybe they don't have it now,
but as a child or something.
So I think, you know, it's like the
Leonard Cohen line there's a crack
in everything.
That's where the light gets in.
And I think it's important
to show that in people who,
in characters who are flawed.
We see it in characters
who are not flawed.
I have to say for,
just for the record,
I did not find Mark and Maggie
>> Hannah Pittard: Thank you.
>> Elizabeth Hand:
unlikeable characters at all.
I thought they were very
real and honestly depicted.
And I thought that your
depiction of Maggie as somebody
who has experienced a
trauma and living with that,
how that changes you and changes
the way you look at the world.
I thought that was really
exceptionally well done.
And to me, that perhaps it didn't
excuse her, some of her behavior.
But it was the explanation
that to me made perfect sense.
And I could also see how Mark
not having had that experience
and not being a woman and not
being vulnerable in the way
that she was and is wouldn't get it.
And would kind of resent
her and would want,
you know, his old wife back.
But I didn't, you know, I
just wanted to say that.
>> Hannah Pittard: No, thank you.
We'd probably be friends.
No, and I promise I'll answer
the question about the dog.
But I was thinking
about this recently
and the trauma that
Maggie experiences.
It's almost as though this is when
she's eaten the apple, and she sees,
you know, she sees the
ugliness of the world.
And Mark hasn't eaten the apple yet.
Because prior to the mugging
they've both been living this sort
of wonderful, complacent in the best
way possible, upper middle class,
very pretty life and
lifestyle together.
And Maggie takes a bite of
the apple, and she starts
to see the world differently.
And by the end of the
book it's, you know,
does Mark basically take
a bite of the apple?
And does he start to see
the world as she does?
But at least they're
going to do it together.
Or, does he not?
And I think that the novel
doesn't answer that question.
But Jerome, the dog, was
always essential to me.
They were never going to be
in the car by themselves.
And part of that is because I
have a dog, and I love dogs.
And the other part of that is
because a dog trainer told me
about two, three years ago, he said,
it must have been longer than that.
Four or five years ago he said.
I'm distracted.
We have ten minutes left just
in case anyone's wondering.
A dog trainer told me that
he can walk into any house
and he knows whether or
not the people in the house
with the dog have been fighting.
And I looked at him and I was
like, do you know that my husband
and I have just been fighting?
And he said, why do
you think I said it?
And I was like, fix our dog, dude.
Fix the dog, and maybe
that will fix the marriage.
And he was telling me something
that Cesar Millan says,
dogs are mirrors of their owners.
And I think that is
absolutely correct.
So I thought, what a fun thing to
give these people something to love.
Which is the thing I
tell my writing students.
I love your advice,
the idea of the people
who are bad don't think they're bad.
I tell them, everybody
loves something.
Humbert Humbert doesn't
just love Lolita.
He loves language.
He has a sense of humor.
He is in awe of America, right.
He can find beauty in anything.
The kitch [phonetic]
is amazing to him.
And so I'm always telling
my students,
don't make the stepmother 100%
evil because she can't be.
That's not interesting.
And so Mark and Maggie, even if
you as a reader can't stand them,
you're going to love
Jerome, and you're going
to love that they love Jerome.
So it's always important to
have something that characters.
And for this childless
couple, it was also essential
that they had something that they
both loved and loved equally.
>> Maureen Corrigan: I
could talk to the two of you
for another three hours, but I know
there are people in the audience
who want to ask questions.
And we are running out of time.
So I'd invite anyone who wants
to ask a question, comment,
please come to the microphone.
>> Hi. Question for Miss Hand.
As a Fantasy Award winner,
do you agree or disagree
with the recent decision to
remove H.P. Lovecraft's likeness
from the award, and why?
>> Elizabeth Hand: Oh well,
you guys think like Trump
and Hillary are a big thing.
I have to say myself I've never
been a Lovecraft fan, per se.
So, I think that, you
know, so I'm not a huge fan
of his fiction, and
I never have been.
There's been a few
stories that I liked,
but he's just not in my wheelhouse.
And he was a racist and an
anti-Semite, and, you know,
those things kind of bleed through
his fiction the way that somebody
like Albert Payson Terhune was
a writer I did love as a kid
and wrote around the same time.
You can't re-read his work
now, or I can't re-read it.
So I was sorry because the image
for the World Fantasy Award
and that's affiliated with the World
Fantasy convention for those of,
most people probably don't know it.
It was Gahan Wilson who is
the New Yorker cartoonist.
Gahan did a caricature
of H.P. Lovecraft.
And it's a great image.
So for that reason, I
was sorry to see it go.
But otherwise, I have to
honestly say that, you know,
I can understand absolutely
the reasons behind it.
So.
>> I'm wondering in your
free time is there is any,
what sort of books do
you yourselves read?
Do you have any favorite
author or authors?
>> Hannah Pittard: I sure do, yeah.
Doris Lessing has been taking
up a lot of my time recently.
And I also, I think she
is a terrifying writer.
And I mean that in the right way.
I read The Fifth Child I
think it's called recently.
And if anyone out there
is on the fence
about having children,
read this book.
And I think it's going to help
you see clearly where you stand.
So Doris Lessing is a go to.
And you're going to want to devour
everything that she has written.
Elizabeth Taylor is somebody
that I have discovered.
I'm reading a novel right
now called Angel by her,
which is about a young
writer with huge ambitions
and a much higher opinion of
her work than she should have.
And it is funny, but it also
manages to be quite disturbing.
Muriel Spark.
These are all strong women writers.
I've certainly, Tim O'Brien
I go to all the time.
In the Lake of the Woods
is probably the book
that I wish I could have
written if I were capable of it
and it hadn't been written.
>> Elizabeth Hand:
I, because I do a lot
of book reviewing and
have for many years.
I teach an MFA program.
So I have to do so much reading of
fiction for work that when I read
for pleasure, which I don't
have as much time to do
as I really would like to.
I tend to read nonfiction,
so I tend to read historical,
you know, books about history.
I like biographies.
I'm not a huge fan of memoirs.
Having said that, recently I read
Hannah's book, which I loved.
I'm reading Elena Ferrante's
My Brilliant Friend,
which I'm finding really
interesting.
And I'm reading a book about 14th,
a village in 14th century
France called [foreign language]
that I've been trying to get
through for a couple of years.
It's a great thing to read at
night before going to sleep
because it's the perfect blend
of like engrossing and
completely tedious.
So you could kind of, you
know, read a page or two.
Well that's enough, which
is why it's taking me
so many years to get through it.
>> Hannah Pittard: My Brilliant
Friend goes back to this idea
where we started of
the opening sentence.
The entire opening chapter,
I don't know how she did it.
You have to read the
whole book to see.
But it's, I still, I think
this, you can't do this.
But how? I mean it's a
mystery and it's all there,
but it's also nothing is there.
It's just mind blowing.
It's an absolutely mind blowing
opening to a novel that seems to be
about nothing to do with it.
But it has everything to do with it.
And then when you get to
the end of the series,
>> Maureen Corrigan:
She comes back to that.
>> I have a question about story
structure for both authors.
I'm curious about how you find,
or to what extent it is applicable
or useful to use the ideas of the
Joseph Campbell Hero's Journey type
of story architecture
as you're writing.
>> Elizabeth Hand: Yeah,
I have found that useful.
I tend to be kind of a seat
of the pants organic writer.
I don't really outline
as much as I should.
But when I'm forced to try to think
through a schematic for a story,
I do some, I do sometimes
think of that.
But I, I don't follow it very
rigorously I have to say.
>> Hannah Pittard: I'm a fairly
instinctive writer as well.
I do, I tell my students, you know,
every story is either a hero takes a
journey or a stranger comes to town.
And sometimes I find myself
saying that and I think,
what does that even mean?
I don't know.
I mean maybe, I hope it helps you.
I don't outline much
either until I get stuck.
And for me the way through a
book is often writing the end.
And so if I have enough at the
beginning, if I've gotten halfway
through and I know I
don't want to abandon it.
But I feel stuck.
I think it's a lot like reading the
last chapter or the last sentence.
I think, where do I want them to be.
And this was the case
with Listen to Me.
I had a realization.
I didn't know what they
needed to be doing in the car.
I didn't know really yet what the
book was about, but I had an image
in my head of the ending.
And so I wrote the end, and then
it just, it sort of fell together.
You know, it tumbled
to the conclusion.
>> Maureen Corrigan: I think we
have time for one more question.
>> I wanted to ask,
did you always know
that writing was what you wanted to
do, or was it coming to that more
of a process each of you.
>> Hannah Pittard: Oh I've
always wanted to be a writer.
I didn't think it was
possible I thought
that it was a fantasy,
a 100% fantasy.
No, and it is, I'm
grateful for it every day.
I love it.
It's the best job in the world.
It's the hardest job in the world.
I absolutely love it.
>> Elizabeth Hand: Yeah
what she said, exactly.
Really, you know, I've always
wanted to be a writer, and I never,
you know, I'm still amazed, I'm
amazed that I'm here, you know.
Truly, every day, all the time.
Any time if I'm in a bad mood
or self-pitying or whining
about something, I'll stop and
think, could you ever have imagined
that you would have done this?
That you would have
written books, you know.
Because I was a relatively
late bloomer
by today's standards, you know.
I didn't really publish until
I was about 30, early 30s.
So there was a long time
where I felt like, oh my God,
this is just never,
ever going to happen.
I'm delusional.
So yeah, I'm very grateful for it.
>> Maureen Corrigan: And so are we.
Thank you.
>> Hannah Pittard: Thank you.
>> Elizabeth Hand: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.